we have a voicemail number it's two one
nine two david key our voicemail line is
made possible by our good friends over
at linguist who want to help you take
your language learning to the next level
I've been using linguist myself to brush
up on my French in advance of a return
to the French countryside and I love it
because it uses artificial intelligence
to adjust to your skill level I've taken
French before I'm not sitting there
wasting time rehashing stuff I already
know it's really great try it out for
free no credit card needed at linguist
comm slash Pakman Li ng VI st.com
slash Pakman support our supporters
really important today's voicemail the
kansas troll has been calling in for
years his calls are often racist he
makes racist calls to sam cedars program
he once called in and completely
imploded during live calls he now is
taking credit for the success of the
david pakman show take a listen to this
hey pac man hey man it's kansas from the
785 so well this is not really
pertaining to any of your nonsense
garbage trash videos i just wanted to
acknowledge that you know david i'm
major show what it is I made you David
your sub your subscriptions your sub
compound has only gone up because of me
you know my first voicemail was played
in 2012 and it basically shows that I
run your show I've made you who you are
so anyways my question for this voice
memo can be are you dating Pat you know
I remember that you dated Louise and he
was your boyfriend you guys were
boyfriends together um is your new
co-host the the boyfriend could you let
me know David I was thinking about
becoming a member
thanks bye yes of course he's just about
ready to become a member after seven
years he's just borderline and if I
address whether Pat and I are dating I'm
sure he will sign up right away
listen anyone who thinks that five
voicemails like that over a seven-year
period can make a show probably is not
going to have any sense talked into them
so we'll leave it there we've got a
great bonus show for you today
how a scanned
with no sex money or illegal behavior is
causing a major problem for Canadian
Prime Minister Justin Trudeau we will
talk about Trump wanting to make
daylight savings time permanent daylight
saving time permanent although it's
unclear that that's actually what he
means and we will talk about Milo you
Napoles being banned from Australia all
of those stories and more on the bonus
show sign up get instant access @ww join
pakman.com free and half-price
memberships available if you get in
touch at david at david pakman.com and
say I want one of Joshua's free
memberships or if you can afford it I
want one of Joshua's half-price
memberships really great stuff thanks to
Joshua you'll get instant access to the
bonus show and I will speak to you in
mere minutes on that bonus show